how are you Brent hey rich rich I'm
great listen you guys you and the
producers you deserve oh man a pat on a
bound I'm so proud of you guys
for trying to help resurrect little
Jimmy brick Meyers career we all know
the problems we all know the problems
that he had of the past but if anybody
if anybody can help brick Meyer it's you
rich and and I know Dan Patrick he's
gonna weigh in with you too and I hear
that Bobby cost is gonna open up this
season man it's just great when you
reach down to help such a troubled such
a troubled broadcaster as brookmire yeah
well he says that you stole all the
Tostitos from him
Brent is that is that true or what do
you know I got paid I get paid by a
company to drop the name I got a nose
for a week what are you talking about
okay he talking about no Martha man's
delusional we know he's got mental
problems to break down you know his wife
was having all those affairs that he
lost it and so he was said to broadcast
me in purgatory you know you know rich
it's really interesting their brows as
we started beasts in here in Las Vegas
and that brick Meyer was having trouble
getting a job so so he called our
executives and you know I gotta be
perfectly honest and don't don't tell
anybody okay but we always we always
talk to prospective announces just to
get an idea do they really know anything
about sports gambling or are they just
pretending and I got to tell you a
general manager interviewed brookmire
and asked him about a three-team parlay
and and I and our boy Jimmy neat thought
that that was two hookers with him in a
Morristown hotel you know Jesus we would
have loved to help him out but yeah Wow
but we just can't okay so I wish you the
best of luck I hope he yeah I hope you
know what once he gets through a couple
of days that people send
tapes you know I review play-by-play
tapes and and and and maybe I can help
you move out of Morristown but hey what
about the draft next week you guys at
the NFL Network you got all the latest
on it you can bet on it in Nevada we got
the Raiders I was down at their new
ticket office here yesterday you know
they're gonna go vertical with the
stadium
what do you mean to make sure you got a
spot for Rich Eisen to the boys they
come in here for primetime game could
have been great what do you mean by
going vertical what do you mean that
means that they're gonna start to put
the steel up next week
okay the foundation is ready okay when
you go vertical on a project that's when
the construction starts to go up word
got out of the hole okay
steel has been delivered and we're ready
to go baby we are ready to go this is
gonna happen I can't believe it it is it
is rich it really is gonna happen have
you heard that uh that the league is
actually considered bringing the draft
to Vegas have you have you heard I have
as a matter of fact I've got a story a
new journal okay about it tomorrow and
between you and me okay and again keep
this to yourself I know you're great at
this the league has already been around
town looking at prospective sites
obviously they got the new stadium we we
know that we know that that stadium will
host the Super Bowl in the future but
it's kind of a big thing for a we'll see
how the graft works out with the Cowboys
this week down and down and our did
t-mobile the more intimate but this is
strictly between you and me they're
taking a look at Fremont Street okay
okay think about that for a big display
down I'm marching fans I'm telling you
now Vegas will break the record for
having fun at a draft party so you're
saying that like outdoors on free entry
yes I remember there's a cover over that
Street now okay that's Ralph's right now
listen those cheerleaders will send
those cheerleaders on that zip line
right down overhead maybe you know maybe
that chick from the USA Today maybe
she'll take a ride at that
you are on fire right now Brent
Musburger here on the Rich Eisen show
okay so how so give me the temperature
of hockey in that town right now Frank
this you know and give me what we're
we're in the history of sports I'm
serious have we seen a story like this
one Brent I don't think we've ever seen
it because you know listen we have got I
was just checking some of the numbers
before the season started and I found
globally that you could get as much as
twenty thousand to one on the Vegas
Golden Knights to win the Stanley Cup
and now you can only get about five to
one four and a half to one some it it is
an incredible story and if you had said
to me if you and I had a conversation
before the start of this season hmm
I would have said you know Vegas not
really a hockey town which I you know I
don't know how they're gonna do they
have exploded everywhere you go in this
city now you see shirts or hats or
t-shirts the logo
last I checked was the best-selling logo
in the National Hockey Leggett it's a
great logo even as they went over to Los
Angeles for two games in which they won
both of course is swept away the kings
there will houses of people I mean in
excess of a thousand sending the team
off on its way on the bus to go to the
airport it is a remarkable remarkable
story the thing you need the thing you
need when you compete obviously you've
got to start with that goaltender and
Marc Andre flurry won three Stanley Cups
while he was with the Pittsburgh
Penguins he anchors this team but the
general manager McPhee and the scouts
rich did an outstanding job of assessing
where hockey is headed today you know in
my era I'll give you a six foot to six
foot three inch defenseman big burly guy
let's uh let's have some enforcers back
there the league has changed
dramatically they're featuring speed
much more like European hockey used to
be a decade or so ago and the Vegas
Golden Knights have four
lines that they use regularly on the ice
a coach gallant gets along so well with
the players and he's got veteran
leadership inside the inside the
dressing room so it has been it has been
a remarkable sports story now let make
no mistake the San Jose Sharks are going
to be better competition for them than
the then the Kings wound up and this can
be a tough series they do have a great
home ice advantage up there on the shark
tank it's going to be the Battle of two
very vocal crowds going forward the
National Hockey League does an
interesting thing when series ends early
in the next match is that they always
wait for the round to be over so the
Golden Knights and the Sharks have got a
lot of time off I'm assuming they'll
start next Thursday or Friday with a
game one of this series and so it's
going to be very interesting but to your
point rich this town has their you know
the sad story the the horrible shooting
of October 1st and the Knights were born
that month and they kind of brought this
city back together it was a it was a
rallying cry that Las Vegas badly needed
the Golden Knights on opening night
treated the victims with such great
respect and the first responders walked
out they brought individual hockey
players and the Golden Knights out to
the center of the ice there wasn't a dry
eye in the house and the city's gone
forward with this team and I'm assuming
that they're also going to embrace the
Raiders because I asked so many
questions about them and I was down at
their ticket off I said it's been busy
the last three days people in there with
their seat license money and they want
to be there when the new arena opens up
to 2020 and so this is this is a city
that I think a lot of people didn't
think would become a huge sports city
but we've got a community here you know
you can't rally around a slot machine
that just that just doesn't work ok but
you give them a couple of sports teams
the biggest basketball team when they
were rolling under Tarkanian now the
hockey team and and the Raiders will be
next this is a great great Sports City
couple more minutes here with Brent
Musburger V sin
his spot for my guys in the desert every
single day from 6 to 8 p.m. Eastern 3 to
5 locally they're in Las Vegas Nevada
what do you think it can happen at the
top of this draft Brent what do you
think should happen what do you think is
gonna happen here you know I'm rich
along the talk lately is about the
quarterbacks and I'm always suspicious
of the evaluation of quarterbacks
because I think that the league makes
more mistakes then they get right if you
go back historically and and look at the
quarterbacks who've been taken in the
first round or the third round let me
let me just throw Russell Wilson out
okay I believe the Seahawks got him in
that they're around memory serves me
correct I had recovered him in Wisconsin
I believe that they put too much focus
on quarterbacks at the combine and some
of the interviews and they don't go back
and look at tapes so I would think that
if I had the first pick in the draft
I've got to get somebody who I think is
gonna help me immediately and ie there
are some defensive players out there and
say Quan Barclay looks like the best
all-around offensive player there's a
Penn State running back but but Richard
sounds like it's going to be quarterback
roulette again judging from now I don't
you know I don't know enough to do a
mock draft or anything like that but I
but I do read the fellows you know
nfl.com I go over there I listen to you
guys on the NFL Network with ESPN I'll
go to the CBS what well I'll check guys
with I think you've got credibility and
everything I'm reading and hearing is
that there's going to be a run on these
quarterbacks right away and I just think
that and here I have in Las Vegas I
think it's a huge gamble i subbed the
defensive end from North Carolina State
I would certainly consider him
fitzpatricks a great defensive back I
covered him at Alabama James is a good
safety coming out of Florida State but
he missed a year with a bad bad injury
broke one Smith the linebacker at
Georgia those are the guys that I would
move to plug in I I honestly at the tie
would follow the Eagles roadmap to the
Superbowl they use pre agencies
well last year and then they plugged in
for a defensive corner to help them out
defensively I I just find that
quarterbacks are a huge huge gamble but
I think we're headed in that direction
Brent loved the time really appreciate
it like I said I'm more than happy to do
a home at home I'm more than happy to to
always return the favor
you're you're the best is there again is
there anything I could say to to Jim its
Brock Meyer by the way is there anything
I could do to broken a Sprunt oh ok geez
I'm sorry Donna does brick fire anyway
hmm listen wish wish him the best okay
with the with the frakkers at Morristown
tell him tell him
Miss Emily to tape and make sure he
doesn't sound like a bad cartoon
character on it okay I'll do it maybe I
can maybe I can help you move up the
chain we're going to have a we're going
to have a new stadium and a new nickname
here in Las Vegas okay for our
minor-league team next year and maybe I
can help the rascal out I would I wish
him the best he's so delusional and
listen let him go at it or all the
Tostitos baby you're the best Brent take
care we'll chat soon okay there's Brent
Musburger you're in the Rich Eisen show
coming in so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience